a brand new apartment complex is now  open near downtown las vegas  at symphony park gave bait news now a  tour of its new space here it is  developers say it offers luxury spaces  kind of like what you would find at a  resort they also highlight  the downtown location  you know it's really a dream come true  to get things up and running and you  know this is going to be an incredible  part of the city it already is and it's  continuing to grow  and we are we're really bullish and  excited to be here  it is a bustling part of las vegas hey  there are still units available if  you're interested complex also offering  500 off if you sign a lease within 24  hours of visiting